[Music]
on this tuesday night could we be on the
verge of another
federal election the opposition is going
to have to decide whether they want to
make this minority parliament work
we are going to study the liberal
corruption virus the political tug of
war that could trigger a trip to the
ballot box
this fall a small supply of vital
equipment
causing big problems i want to run out
of the building screaming
global news investigates the desperation
at canada's kobit 19 labs
will halloween be scary or not i think
it's just
frustrating to have so many mixed
messages the tricky subject
among health experts and an astronomical
expedition the secrets this asteroid
could unearth about the universe
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are watching some political
maneuvering going on in ottawa
right now that could depending on how
things unfold
trigger a federal election this fall a
showdown is looming over a push by the
conservatives to put the spotlight back
on the trudeau government's connections
to the we charity and what the
conservatives claim is a misuse of tax
dollars
the tories want a special committee
formed which they would control
the liberals accuse them of playing
political games and are calling their
bluff by making it a confidence vote
the opposition parties have a choice do
they want to make parliament work
and work for canadians or do they want
to vote non-confidence and trigger
election
the choice mr speaker is theirs now no
party says they actually want an
election
or at least they don't want to be the
one that triggers it david aiken is
watching all this david help us dissect
what's happening
well donna this has got to be the most
canadian of parliamentary spats it's a
process heavy dispute
over the establishment of a
parliamentary committee and yet
prime minister justin trudeau says he is
ready to plunge the country
into an election unless at least one of
the opposition parties
drops the idea of creating this
committee
we hope that opposition parties will
decide that they want to make parliament
continue to work for canadians
and not side with the conservatives
who've decided that they no longer have
confidence in this government
conservatives say the government is
overreacting and that while they do not
want an election
they do want to fulfill their
parliamentary function of holding the
government to account
over the we charity matter we are going
to study
and fight the coronavirus
but we're also going to study at
committee the liberal corruption virus
there are some discussions among the
parties to find a compromise but
it may come down to the ndp to avoid
bringing the government
down jagmeet sang says he cannot
conceive of an election being fought
in a pandemic over the composition of a
parliamentary committee
that is outrageous and is absurd
and he criticized trudeau for putting
politics above those he was elected to
serve
there are a lot of canadians that are
feeling a lot of pain right now
and are worried about more pain to come
david the last federal election you'll
remember was a year ago could we really
be on the cusp of another one
well it's possible and it would
certainly be the first one
ever sparked over the formation of a
committee
in any event we will find out how it all
plays out when the issue comes to a vote
shortly after 3 p.m eastern tomorrow
afternoon
donna all right stand by david aiken in
ottawa thank you
confusion still lingers over the future
of nova scotia's lobster fishery
tensions have been escalating for months
both indigenous and commercial
harvesters say federal officials
are not doing enough to resolve
questions about indigenous fishing
rights
as ross lord reports some say they're
getting mixed signals
the finer points of a so-called moderate
livelihood for indigenous fishers are
still elusive
even for the prime minister it is work
that needs to be done
properly respectfully and in partnership
with everyone involved in a
nation-to-nation relationship and
bringing along
the commercial fishery community as well
but commercial and
indigenous harvesters say they're
getting mixed signals from federal
authorities
in cape breton fishers licensed by the
boltletech first nation
say the department of fisheries and
oceans is undercutting their livelihood
by seizing lobster traps they were
removing any traps that were not
tagged with authorized tags from dfo
now our tags are issued to us from
our band under our own livelihood plan
self-governing ourselves
commercial fishers complain there are
far more indigenous traps in the water
than the 550 included in sebagon
aggety's new fishery
they point to a shipment of lobster
copped by indigenous fishers in 2017
in these same waters the shipment of
almost three metric tons was
intercepted by dfo and a chinese plant
owner was convicted of illegally selling
the catch
leaders on both sides say the lack of
agreement opens the door to more
violence like the weekend fire that
burnt down a lobster pound
that did business with indigenous
fishers our people are out there yeah
very limited trap supply but they're
there and there hasn't been any
commercial boats out there in a couple
of days now
federal fisheries minister bernadette
jordan says she'll appoint
a special representative this week
another attempt
to reach a common understanding ross
lord global news
halifax now to the pandemic a couple of
things to bring you up to date on
manitoba is reporting another spike in
new cases there were
110 positive cases in the past 24 hours
in manitoba
outbreaks have been declared at an
elementary school and in three personal
care homes in winnipeg
manitoba still has the highest number of
active cases per capita
in canada in quebec 877 new cases were
reported today
tight restrictions are already in place
in quebec city and montreal and now
the city of joliet and surrounding areas
will move into the red zone as well on
friday
cases are still on the rise in parts of
ontario too more than 800 new infections
were reported today
at the same time testing numbers have
dropped just over 24 000 tests were
processed in the last 24 hours the
fewest
in a single day since early september
people had been waiting up to a week
for their test results today premier
doug ford ford claimed
that backlog has been cleared we had a
little blip there for
a week two weeks now it's all caught up
so anyone is going to get a test you can
get a result almost
immediately a day later two days later
there is another problem that is putting
a strain on covid19 testing in canada
as our chief investigative correspondent
carolyn jarvis reports a small but
crucial piece of equipment
is in short supply pipet tips pipette
tips
pipette tips here's something no one
expected to be talking about
seven months ago pipette tips a tiny
piece of plastic that's crucial in a
covet 19 test
and the latest part of the supply chain
that's nearly impossible to get
we thought that supply chain was secure
and
lo and behold our delivery doesn't show
up i never thought in a million years
i would be trying to find pipette tips
from
you know any supplier that i can and
it's not just pipette tips
any sort of plastic used in kova testing
referred to as
consumables is running dangerously short
this document obtained by global news
was put out by ontario health in the
last week
and lists 15 different types of plastics
used by labs
that are in short supply many of them at
high risk
we contacted the companies listed and
only one of them responded
saying because of american demand
getting any product out of the us
is impossible and they're now looking to
china like all of that back corner with
the yellow tags those are all pipette
tips
this never before seen footage taken
inside the shared hospital lab at
toronto's sunnybrook health sciences
center
shows a stockpile of these scarce
plastics if you run out of one
piece of your algorithm the whole lab
comes to a halt
at st joseph's hospital in hamilton a
former office
is now a secret storage closet so this
is gold
this is gold and these boxes will only
last
two weeks the fact that we even have to
like lock up our supplies and gloves
and keep them in an area so that other
people don't know about it
it's unbelievable some distribution
companies have now taken to rationing
items
and that's frustrating to just see the
the equipment sit there idle
for the people trying to figure out how
to make do without
the pressure is crushing i want to run
out of the building screaming
uh and and i have to tell you our
laboratory technologists
are you know having moments where they
have to stop
and and cry to survive labs that have
are sharing with those that don't and if
a lab still can't process tests
samples are being shipped elsewhere this
is not a normal
procedure this is full-time crisis
wartime mode the question many are now
asking is why hasn't canada secured a
domestic supply chain for its labs like
it did with ppe
the federal government says it has
signed contracts with companies to
secure some supplies in canada
but the bottom line is labs are still
struggling
donna carolyn jarvis in toronto thanks
october 31st is fast approaching and
canadians are coming up with creative
ways to celebrate halloween
dozens of paddle boarders dressed up for
a halloween costume party in toronto's
harbor
in mississauga these witches swap their
brooms for boards
trick-or-treating though is going to be
different this year in some places it's
been cancelled and others
seriously modified now is not the time
for lots of close contact
as heather urix west explains halloween
is yet another tradition
complicated by covid19
when you're a kid it doesn't get much
better than this
a chance to dress up be with your
friends and collect
candy so it's no wonder there's a lot of
disappointment in cities like toronto
where trick-or-treating has effectively
been cancelled
i think it's just frustrating to have so
many mixed messages and halloween
is a big deal and kids are outside mixed
messages because outside of ontario's
hot zones
trick-or-treating is still going ahead
even in cities like edmonton
where covet 19 cases are on the rise i
have no plans to suggest that alberta
cancel halloween this year my own
children would never forgive me
in many ways halloween is actually safer
to celebrate
than other holidays if you think about
traditional trick-or-treating
if you really do stay outdoors the whole
time if you really do stick with
your family uh keep you know put on
masks avoid crowds
and are mindful about hand hygiene this
is about as low risk as it gets
but ontario's premier says in the midst
of a second wave that has yet to peak
his province's talk doctors disagree i
have to take the advice of the chief
medical officer which i have
and move forward with it which means no
trick-or-treating in toronto
or ottawa the prime minister says his
own family plans to heed local advice
listening to public health officials
means that my family will not
be going trick-or-treating this year but
what about in communities where public
health officials have said
trick-or-treating is okay it's important
to check with your local health
authority because toronto isn't the only
hot spot
craig jenny says if you're heading out
review local guidelines
and make sure costumes include a mask
the big key though to remember is that a
halloween mask is not the same as a
medical mask
and we would ask that if you're going to
wear a mask that you're doing so still
with
the kind of mask you would wear to the
supermarket or the schools
it's said to be yet another holiday
unlike any other
halloween undercover 19. heather urex
west global news calgary
in the u.s which has the most cases of
covet 19 and the most deaths millions of
people are not waiting
until november 3rd to vote a record 35
million people have voted early in the
presidential election
though it's not easy for everyone voter
suppression discouraging or preventing
certain groups
of people from casting a ballot is a
real issue for millions of americans
as jackson proskow explains the us is
one of the few western democracies that
makes it difficult for citizens
to have their say they say everything's
bigger in
texas and in sprawling harris county
home to houston
this is the incredible line to return a
mail-in ballot
there's just one drop box for four and a
half million residents
it really does not make sense it's
totally inconvenient
but we had to do it instead of making it
easier to vote during the pandemic the
governor of texas made it harder
ruling each county could only have one
box claiming it's an issue of election
security
anytime you see governments i think
trying to
take actions that appear to make voting
harder
it should raise questions experts see
yet another attempt at voter suppression
in a country full of examples
state after state has purged millions of
eligible voters from the rolls
in many states the deadline to register
to vote has come and gone
then there are the increasingly strict
voter id laws
unlike canada which has universal voter
registration
which has a national uniform method for
federal elections
and which has uh national voter rolls
none of those exist in the united states
it's up to each state to decide how the
election is administered
in georgia where there's a long history
of voter suppression
black voters are more likely to face
long waits to vote than white voters
in pennsylvania there have been running
court battles over which votes should
count
the supreme court ruled that mail-in
ballots returned up to three days after
the election are valid
despite the objections of republicans
where we are heading is that we are
headed to
complete degrading of our democracy we
will essentially exist
as a democracy in name but none in fact
it'll end up being a rigged election
even president donald trump's own words
about the election are seen as a way of
discouraging voters
despite so many obstacles it may all be
having the opposite effect
drawing historic early turnout with
americans more determined than ever to
vote
jackson prosko global news washington
a police officer found not guilty in the
death of a black man in ottawa
coming up the reasons for the verdict
and why the victim's family
is devastated
an ottawa police officer has been found
not guilty in the case of a black man
who died after a violent arrest
abdulrahman abdi who struggled with his
mental health died in 2016.
constable daniel mancian pleaded not
guilty to manslaughter aggravated
assault and assault with a weapon
the case centered on the officer's use
of force during the arrest
michael couture reports on the verdict
and the reaction
and a warning some of the video in his
story may be disturbing
the family is devastated by the decision
abdi
raman abdi's brother jama was at a loss
for words moments after the verdict
this was not the result they expected we
were
in telephone contact with other members
of the family
they are truly devastated by the
decision
four years ago police were called about
reports that abdirahman abdi
had assaulted women near a coffee shop
after unsuccessful attempts to arrest
him constable daniel mancion arrived on
the scene as backup
delivering several blows to abdi's face
and head
while wearing reinforced gloves an
autopsy revealed the somali-born man
suffered a heart attack over the course
of the arrest
and died the following day as a result
of brain hypoxia
something that factored in justice
robert kelly's decision
writing i am left in a state of
reasonable doubt
about whether constable monsien's acts
caused mr abdi's death
unlike other times during this 72-day
long trial
constable monsieur avoided the media
tuesday
allowing his lawyers to speak for him
instead he feels
as i said earlier greatly relieved that
this
ordeal is over and looking forward to
going back
into the service late tuesday a peaceful
protest in support of the family
had one clear message this so-called
justice system
continues to fail continues to fail to
protect
a certain segment of the population and
in particular
black indigenous and racialized people
monsieun still faces disciplinary
charges under the police services act
this trial has echoed calls for better
police training
evidence revealed abdi struggled with
mental health
while the police union welcomes more
training and mental health help
it points out abny's mental health was
never communicated to responding
officers
this was a call for criminal sexual
assault in this situation you would
never dispatch somebody
from the mental health field to this
call we would that would be completely
appropriate be unsafe for the person
the family is pursuing a civil lawsuit
against the police officer and while
they know it won't bring back abdi
they hope it will result in change to
the system so that this
doesn't happen to another family mike
lacouter global news ottawa
bolstering broadband still ahead the
internet plans speeding up in canada
much of central vietnam is under water
as the region braces for a third cyclone
this month
six times the normal amount of rainfall
has already fallen in october and
flooding is extensive at least 100
people have died more than 90 thousand
others have been displaced by the rising
water
and landslides spacex has moved a step
closer to launching its satellite
internet service in canada
the canadian radio television and
telecommunications commission has
approved the company's application for a
license to provide a high-speed service
called
starlink lots of canadians who live in
rural areas support the idea
they long for fast and affordable
internet service starlink has more than
800 satellites in orbit though not all
are operational
spacex founder elon musk wants to add
thousands more
his goal is to offer high-speed internet
to rural areas
everywhere canadians don't have access
to it yet starlink still needs to test
the service which could begin in canada
and the northern u.s later this year
moss plans to expand to near global
coverage by 2021.
an astonishing asteroid mission next
what's happening right now
320 million kilometers from earth
an intricate operation has just taken
place far far away from us in space
nasa's osiris-rex spacecraft touched the
surface of an asteroid
vacuuming up some precious samples as
mike gerlay reports getting to this
point has taken years of intense and
complex work
and finally the engineers have watched
it all pay off
for a few seconds osiris-rex kissed the
asteroid known as bennu
allowing its vacuum to suck up a few
kilos of rocks
orex msa on orex ops sample collection
is complete
and the back away burn has executed
[Music]
and just like that it was off again its
mission now to return its valuable cargo
home
for scientists to study you bring back
that amount of material to earth-based
laboratories
and it's it's literally christmas for
the next 10 years for uh
scientists here on earth scientists say
the material on bennu hasn't changed
since the universe was formed studying
it could unlock secrets to how planets
and life began
and lip off of osiris-rex osiris-rex
launched in 2016 with a clear mission
get close enough to an asteroid with a
diameter roughly the height of the cn
tower
and scoop up some of its sandy surface
except as osiris-rex got closer
the images it sent back threw the
mission a curveball
instead of sand bennu was covered with
enough rocks
that nasa put osiris in orbit for a year
to find a clear enough spot to continue
the mission
they originally expected to be able to
put the spacecraft down in a mall let's
say he had 100 parking spots
but now with the danger associated with
the boulders the strewn
nature of the surface they've got to put
it down to like within half a dozen
parking spots bennu and osiris are on
the other side of the universe
320 million kilometers away
so far that it takes 18 and a half
minutes to transmit a message back to
earth
so nasa engineers could only program
osiris and wait
they'll get their first images tomorrow
and then wait some more until 2023
to see osiris's precious cargo in person
mike relay global news toronto and that
is global national for this tuesday i'm
donna friesen tonight's your canada is
valdesource it means valley of springs
and it's the new name residents of the
quebec town of asbestos have chosen
it was once home to the world's largest
asbestos mine that shut down in 2011 and
residents hope the rebrand will shed the
town of ties to the toxic material
thanks for watching and hope to see you
here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye
[Music]